[Music] [
Music] There is
no equipment, no machinery, nothing
final. Simple equipment, all from the civil defense brothers,
and simple equipment from the civil world. This is the
work of man in general today, anyone.
[Music]
[Music] And we
are coming to attack Turkey, Adana
ambulances.  It did not stop until we entered Syria. The
situation in Syria is very difficult. There are no
vehicles. There is not enough first aid. There are no
food supplies. There are no tents. There are not enough food supplies.
Medical kits. The hospitals here are crying out for help. They need
medical supplies.
[Music] [
Music]
[Music] [  [
Any European country or any other country with
such devastation would have been aided and all
heavy machinery directed to it. But here in
northwest Syria we have no power or strength
except with God Almighty.